we're joined now by dr tara shirazian a
gynecologist who treats endometriosis
she's also director of nyu
lagoon's center for fibroid care
welcome i think this is such an
important conversation that no one ever
wants to have when it comes to
endometriosis specifically as lux deals
with every single month why do so many
women go undiagnosed why is this such a
problem well i think we have sort of
typical period pain so we're we're the
simulator showcases that very well where
you have this typical pain you have it
monthly it's cyclic a lot of a lot of
patients experience that and then you
have atypical pain pain that's beyond
sort of that normal baseline pain and
that essentially is a hallmark of
endometriosis but because
pain in general menstrual pain is so
common i think it's hard for many people
to know the distinction the difference
and hard to get diagnosed well and i
don't want to rag on male doctors but i
know even for myself i've gone in and
it's like well that you just have to
deal with that right that's that's
normal i think that's a i think that's a
really really big problem out there that
we kind of normalize all of menstrual
pain and so we say well just you know
suck it up and go to work you know just
take the tylenol or advil and go to work
and so we miss the opportunity to
diagnose and especially for young women
young patients it's very very important
to diagnose early because they spend
their reproductive lives in pain so to
know early is very very important what
causes it
it's very interesting so endometriosis
is a condition where cells that normally
are in the lining of the uterus get
displaced into the pelvis so when you
have periods and you cycle those cells
you have pain in places where it
shouldn't be basically throughout the
pelvis near the bladder on the rectum
you know in the vagina or on the top of
the vagina so there's a whole host of
symptoms you have painful sex you have
painful bowel movements you can have
nausea vomiting you can have really bad
bloating and pain so it really goes
above and beyond standard menstrual pain
and how effective is the treatment and
then the big question you always hear
from researchers do you have the money
you need the funding to do it well i
think funding is always an issue you
know and i find that that's true across
a lot of our women's health issues
endometriosis fibroids you know a lot of
them are considered normal or standard
or benign causes of pain so there's not
enough research right we're more focused
on sort of the cancers and less on the
more
benign issues but these affect millions
and millions of patients so it needs
more funding definitely when it comes to
endometriosis the treatment is lifelong
the treatment is lifelong to answer your
other question it is a chronic condition
so patients spend their lifetime
really in pain and we have lots of
treatments but the treatments you know
they're minimal they don't help always
we have you know medications that you
can take we have surgical treatments we
have acupuncture we can diagnose now
with mri at nyu we use a really great
mri device that can pick up small
lesions but still you need to be managed
across your reproductive lifespan so a
teacher once told me there's no such
thing as stupid questions so forgive me
i'm sure yeah go for it um
when it comes to endometriosis or even
just dealing with periods yeah is there
anything that a man can do in those
moments ice cream okay that's all i was
asking i i want to know and then at home
saying ask the question
yes i actually think being sensitive to
the issue is extremely important right
because we just got through saying that
it's you know everyone is just sort of
told it's normal you're complaining too
much it's not that bad right right but
the simulator shows us it is that bad it
is really bad so we need to be
compassionate we need to make sure the
patient has room and space like whatever
she needs right if it's
ice cream or down time or dishes or not
going to work that day you know i think
all of that's reasonable very important
i think it should be a two-way street
though as well i think as a country we
can stop uh laughing at guys you get
that shot in the groin with the football
in the fall right aw
that's still going to be america's
funniest video not every month
that's america's funniest home video
right okay kept that in the pocket all
right dr shirazia thank you so much for
joining us